so the liberal media is begging Biden to
take a page from the 2020 campaign and
just keep the whole thing in the
basement like last time the president
winning big in the New Hampshire primary
despite the fact that his name was not
on the ballot because they decided to
skip New Hampshire so it was all right
in and he never had to come to the
Granite State and campaign and campaign
at all former Obama Aid van Jones thinks
that the secret to securing a Biden
victory in November Maybe by doing the
same strategy all over again and keeping
him out of the public eye listen to this
if I were Biden I would I would stay
hidden and I'll tell you why um he
doesn't Inspire
confidence and he's not a great
messenger for himself Trump's strength
his resilience is really a reflection of
Biden's uh fragility uh Republicans are
not afraid of Joe Biden they're not
afraid so even when he does come out and
meet he ends up meeting with hecklers by
his own party there were Pro Palestinian
agitators interrupting him a dozen times
during a speech yesterday watch this
frankly Donald Trump and magga
Republicans including the woman
[Music]
[Applause]
hollering this going to go on for a
while they got this
[Music]
plan so um you know that woman was
yelling I voted for you yeah I voted for
you um to Joe Biden judge Janine you
know the question is can can the
strategy first of all you got to just
absorb that reaction on the set when
he's saying this when van Jones who I
think is very straightforward says
what's on his mind you know he's like I
I I don't think he he doesn't Inspire
confidence and people around the table
Axel Rod was there just kind of and Cape
bingfield who used to be his press
secretary and was very involved in the
first campaign just kind of like you
know it really is disappointing when you
hear Democrats who you know people
respect them I I respect them for what
they're saying and they're basically
saying you know he does he's not a good
messenger he doesn't inspire people but
what kind of party would put up a
candidate a presidential candidate that
they openly admit doesn't Inspire
confidence he's not a good messenger I
mean are they so desperate for power
that they'd rather appear weak on the
world stage unable to communicate a
concept and subjugate us to Russia and
China and North Korea you know and you
can only have so many surrogates Martha
I mean not that many people can go out
and say you're the greatest president
that ever lived but you know 66% of his
own part party doesn't want him to run
77% of them think he's too old and I
don't think it's age it's cognitive and
so you know you have a nobody like Dean
Phillips 99% of the country doesn't know
who he is he gets 20% in New Hampshire
when he just started a couple months ago
and finally Biden is in trouble with
blacks with young voters with
progressives Hamas as you just saw as
well as the Latinas and you know there's
literally no enthusiasm for this man and
so now he's got a a pack who's going to
give a million dollars to tick tock to
try to get some of these influencers to
say yo he's such a hot character and my
concern is this you know how do the
Democrats you know yell so much about
democracy when they're willing to sell
it short by putting out a guy that they
don't think is the best candidate for
this country so Jess how if you were
advising him how would you tell him to
run his
campaign I would tell him to be out
there as much as possible quite frankly
and we hear a lot about the lack of
enthusiasm Joe Biden it's the first
right in campaign in history what
happened in New Hampshire he's on track
to get more votes than Barack Obama did
in 2012 you talk about Dean Phillips he
got 20% sure but let's talk about the
unity there's only 10% of democratic
voters
self-reporting this that would not
support Joe Biden we are completely
unified the number you expect from an
incumbent right I mean that that's a nor
but we've been talking about Donald
Trump as a quasi incumbent at least he
has a record to run on right he's acting
like he's an incumbent he actually
thinks that he won in 2020 so he's like
half an incumbent and he 50% he gets
50,000 votes and 70% of his competitors
uh voters won't even uh go for him but I
hear about this basement campaign all
the time from 2020 and even from now we
we don't see Joe Biden and it's shocking
that we get all this footage somehow but
he is out there and he's doing
meaningful things he was the united with
the United Auto Workers today getting
their endorsement and the president
talking about how Donald Trump when they
had a strike in 2019 didn't do anything
yesterday he had a rally for
Reproductive Rights in Virginia it's
going to be a crucial issue for us
Monday the reproductive healthc care
access task force the US Conference of
Mayors last Friday he went to Raleigh on
Thursday to talk about brand Broadband
access and to meet with an educator who
had his student loans forgiven and the
impact it's had with his family and by
the way they made some very meaningful
content um out of all of that the man is
not hiding and he's doing well and
Democrats are happy with their choice
well then the choice is going to is
likely to be Trump versus Biden Charlie
and I'm thinking about the moment in New
Hampshire yesterday when um president
Trump was coming out of an event and he
he went over and started talking to
reporters and you could see his people
like we got to go but no no no he wants
to answer more questions and more
questions and more questions all off the
cuff all you know very transparent so
what's this race going to look like
between these two people well I think
it's uh you know I don't think anybody
actually vote except for maybe Jill and
Hunter actually voted for Joe Biden
everybody's voting against the Democrats
are voting against uh uh Donald Trump
which is what the the unity there is but
the thing that I think is most amazing
about what happened yesterday is that
you have in this election where
Democrats are going to try to make it
all about democracy and election
Integrity they conducted a fake election
none of the none of the the votes that
were cast yesterday are going to
actually count which is amazing to me
that they're going to be lecturing us
about elections and and democracy um and
luckily for the Biden Camp uh some
people got together and dragged him
across with the right in Campaign which
is helpful uh for him I guess but I I
don't think that it means that that
there is going to be great Unity once
you get into the into the throws of a
general election no it you you have so
many people Greg David Axelrod van Jones
saying he he doesn't Inspire anyone and
he should stay in the basement but can
that work twice can that work four years
apart when that whole situation was
covid driven at least that was the cover
well his numbers are in the basement so
we can keep a company you know it it
does kind of it's got to suck when the
person you claim you're going to support
and vote for for
president you have to hide I mean that
you actually are saying it out loud that
he's my guy but we can't show him we
can't take him outside but we're willing
to have him as president how can you
hold those thoughts in your head so as
you know I always offer suggestions
because I'm that type of person you know
the pope has a pope mobile yeah I think
they should have a basement mobile and
so they could put Joe in a basement it's
just a moving basement right and he
could just sit there he can have his hot
cocoa maybe some pudding and it just
moves around it's wide and can feel very
comfortable cuz I think the examples
that that Jessica gave of things that
he's doing are kind of layups I mean
student forgiveness and you know
abortion rallies yeah you're killing
loans and babies he's used to that I
think we're building toward a scenario
where Joe Biden will be seen as
Justified not to debate Trump y right we
can't give Trump's evil ideas any
traction I mean CNN and MSNBC have
already done that so I think this is how
I think if he's not doing this
if he's not like even going to bother
campaigning he sure as hell is not going
to debate and I think that's going to
say something what it is I don't know
well Trump will want to debate him you
can guarantee that Trum want to debate
him but Trump didn't show up for any he
didn't have to and public appearances
outside of a courthouse are not really
meaningful he said from the beginning
that he wants toate in the general
election that he said when it comes to
that you would have to debate in the
general election yes and the strength
and the V and the resilience that van
Jones talked about just shows how Jones
loves to blow up Democrats okay so now
we're going to criticize him he is a
well-respected
Democrat I love that you love a Democrat
W I love I love you in spite of what you
think all right so right back at you hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
box you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now